and Godspeed
okay but not long okay well I don't know
what
all right
this let's forget it
this is not that important it's not that
important you all gotta realize where
you are in life just by where you are
now look at where you're sitting in the
Sun look at where we're sitting now this
has nothing to do with who's gonna die
first what you all are sitting in the
Sun everybody's in and as you do this
and as you do that and you're going to
you're sitting in the Sun now the people
that paid your way here and most of you
had your way pay for one reason people
most of you had your way Hey most pay
attention oh you can't be graded anymore
I know that but I got bad news for you
this outside world 75 doesn't get it you
can get into promo 275 but not out here
no no no they've won 110 now let's get
back to what I was saying all these
people sitting around you when you look
at the way they're dressed they're
dressed that way because they have no
money left
you all have been using people
manipulating these people behind you and
now they're back there all those people
back there cuz they're ready to kick but
they are ready to kick but all these
people even the old ones there's some
old ones they had bent over they can't
even see but they can see your butt and
they expect you to make something of
yourself and you have no idea what
you're going to make there's only three
people I saw we're going to be something
one Prowler came up there took
everything away this one away took
everything we ran out of things and then
they said everybody would gold things
hanging or stand up in four or five
people had nothing he just okay you can
see them round there go to San Francisco
go down to the church in Bay but you're
sitting in the Sun keep that in mind
next thing is ask any college graduate
after ten years what do they remember
about the graduation yeah well I went No
okay listen you see me all the time Wow
as long as I live you can you'll be able
to put your children in front of the TV
set in y'all go Drake or something like
that you know how to watch it but the
most important thing the most important
thing is that this particular moment
forget mm forget what you don't get to
mm without 1994 you don't get there
without 1995 you don't get any place
without page1
how many of you read the foreword of any
book
how many of you wave it past your 11th
week of being here before you ask for
car how many of you waited past 15 weeks
you know I needed an apartment all on
the Sham that you were going to college
and sham getting something that you
better have or else you're going to be
doing something you have no control over
now with this degree you have control
you have power you know you don't your
which is a French word that means slave
that groundskeepers made more last night
and most of you will get all year you
will manipulate your parents and lay
around the house and they've got to be
very nice to you words love me be the
only reason they won't kick you out is
because they can go to parties and say
they have a college graduate you don't
have a job they want you doing the
service they want you to go away
somewhere please now I remember
great story
the church and the congregation full
house
the minister is about to speak in the
doors kicked over Pam and there stood
Satan and Satan says congregation turned
around and everybody Oh God
with Shepherd full sentences through a
fire ball bounced around set the walls
of the church on fire started burning
choir Ram Satan said party time the
minister held up a Bible said Satan
begone Satan took the fire bond through
it burned up the ministers role pulpit
on fire congregation started running out
except for one sitting there with
sunglasses on just as can be just kind
of slight a bomb you know chewing on a
half a stick of gum you know Satan
through another fireball rather than now
the churches of blaze winning seven
degrees Farenheit ministers God has seen
turns around and nobody's accepted
sunglasses ever so slightly look at this
ad some kind of fool
Satan came over and said do you know why
your friend
nobody Fred nothing it's important for
you to understand that college does not
teach maturity many of you if you're
going home
your room is still dirty the clothes are
still unwashed and you're still begging
even though you can graduate magna [ __ ]
laude
sivakumar queen lord thank you lord
means nothing unless you do something
with it
and therein lies fear what to do what to
do what do I do
well now even you know you can change
anytime you want to there was a time
when you said well I don't want to I
don't change I read what a regular you
can change you can change tomorrow you
say today me tomorrow and that which you
failed and left and went and came back
but a lot of people going to pass you a
lot of people because that's what this
world is about people with fourth-grade
education gonna pass you because they
had an idea they believed it they took
it to people people said they didn't
believe it then the person said no this
is going to work and they did it and
then they became very wealthy and then
you read about me say I should have done
that then you read stories about some
person who didn't graduate from college
had maybe a seventh grade education and
he took his mother and father's money
five hundred dollars and invested it
somewhere and today they're worth a
billion five do not try this at home you
will be hit about the face and neck by
your relatives what to do what to do
well look at you and then look around
tell your father's story tell your
mother's story tell the story of some
uncle are these real people did they
work for a living
what do you think of them in the
position they're in are you above them
below them
have they anything to offer you how
comfortable are you those of us and I
mean us because when I entered a college
Temple University I'm all A's and the
first
paper I got back with a c-plus on it I
said well that's not bad not bad then I
began to dislike certain people
rightfully so some of them setting the
curve didn't care for them at all the
curve centers we had meetings with them
in the janitor's closet tried to tell
them to set it lower you know but some
of these people are horrible people
they won't lower the curve they keep
saying to you know you have to do better
they're not professors they're students
and I said that to Ramon as a Ramon
you're a damn student what a trash like
wine you're not being paid by this
university give me the answers let me
copy your paper Ramon what the hell's
the matter with you don't you realize
you're one of us but Ramon Judas
he didn't even want to have meetings
with us the night before the exam so
those of us who hadn't read could hear
Ramon's girlfriend so who are you and
what are you well for today here's
what's happening the news is you've made
some people very very happy and as a
matter of fact they're you know how
something can be not as good but people
are just so happy to have it it's called
small but thank you Lord that's what
some of you are going to do for some
people today it's a moment for them and
it's also a moment for you but it's not
a big deal I'm telling you walk around
take that thing off and get started you
started on you you started moving put
the acid
teach yourself maturity that's what we
parents want from you that's all we ask
they will back you up as you well know
these are the greatest suckers on the
face of this earth parents the greatest
suckers on the face of this earth I mean
where else will you get people to cry
and you because you took them to sizzler
you give your father raggedy-ass tie the
man goes crazy and inside he said what a
piece of these people love you you know
it now it's time to quit playing do
something for you know I'm important the
reason why they're there is because of
love your hugs your kisses and now it's
time for you to begin to tell the truth
okay never mind
I give up this last story is my own it
happened to me in sure enough real life
and then I have to take a plane and and
get out of here and move on I'm very
very serious I want to be serious and
then I want to tell my mom I joke when
Ennis died mrs. Cosby and I felt a loss
I'm telling all of you this because you
are here and you're alive you're here
and you're alive there are some of us
here and out there we've lost a child
and you will always be our children no
matter how old you become it's the worst
part of life being a parent no matter
how old you are your children will
always be your children how do you have
any job yes how old are 74 if if you can
not make your life so rough the
challenges that you feel are challenges
how many shots of scotch can drink
without puking on yourself
you know is that really a challenge or
have you lost your mind
how fast can you drive how long can you
go with your eyes closed
talking stupidity
how much what can you smoke how many
pills can you take how high can you get
well let's start with some things of
remembering that your life and if you
contribute to ending it or if someone in
your life there's always something
missing you will be missing love hope
memories
laughter sadness a willingness to want
to hug and the people behind you today
if anything means anything solid forget
whether you have a job or not
today is a day I swear to god when you
see them all of them that hug that's
what to me today is about and in the
spirit of of innis William who was a
terrific fighter and was going to save
an awful lot of kids in his spirit I I
will save you that I see you I don't
care how old you are as you sit out
there I see in us and I hope that in you
is that spirit which is still in spirit
for you to continue not to worry about
the height of the ladder
if you set goals you have no problem if
you set one goal you become frightened
because that's bigger than anything sit
three or four for yourself that way you
can take a couple down and put some more
up keep a smile we're an annoying person
would ordinarily give some sort of
wisecrack it's not difficult to do but
mostly when you get that chance to hug
be honest this time be real this time
cuz it's time I was in Temple University
political science teacher dr. LeBlanc
professor in Leblon one of those
professors who would stop in the middle
of the lecture and look at you and say
if there was only one Baltimore Oriole
what song would he sang and of course
you know you'd sit trying to get that
aid he left and he's three hours Tuesday
and Thursday nobody had the answer until
two minutes before the end of class and
Ramone stood up and said he always kept
his hands in his pocket you can hear
changed yeah that's another reason why I
didn't like him you can hear change in
his property and he said would sing his
own song his or her own song I believe
professor yes that is correct and only
gotten a and but I knew the answer but I
didn't say it I had I was afraid to say
it because the answer is so dumb I mean
I felt that way one time when I was in
elementary school and the teacher said
what is the
mission of darkness and I knew the
answer but the answer was so stupid
because it's so simple I didn't want to
say it then finally somebody said well
darkness is the absence of light and I
said I knew that but I didn't say it
because it's stupid and that's an
obvious answer but as I was riding home
on the subway I just felt so good about
being in college my god college my alpha
waves were just kicking on the inertia
had been stimulated Thursday I went back
to class dr. LeBlanc was somewhere I
don't know in the middle or the end of
Hegel's theory of dialectical
materialism and canden said is the glass
half full or half empty
and we went out it for three hours we
went at it and the best part is Ramone
didn't get it either it was over and we
all cheered with it yes and we weren't
cheering because we didn't get the
answer we were jaegers Ramon didn't get
it we was all happy yes Mon you scum but
still under subway I felt so stimulated
so moved so every my lord thank you
because i'm in college and i looked at
the people on public transportation
reading newspapers magazines letting
these things tell them what to do and
how to live
I am Who I am tapped out went home and I
couldn't get in the house I didn't have
a key
my mother didn't give me one that my
father said she was practicing me for
when I get married I just saw them
they're all very old when you look here
everybody's young they think you're
looking at those guys they've made it
all these people have made it they
thanks well no they say they've they've
all gone forth they've seen forth soon
as you see forth your face gets old
force comes right up to you hi I'm
fourth you've been looking for me not
really so I went down to Grandma and
granddad's house which is two blocks
away Brenda and grandma's house
grandma's making biscuits
she's with the dough she opens the door
he's got dough in her hand and she can
turn around nob with her elbow I find
that to be very very special but I don't
say anything you know because he
sometimes would openly say how'd you do
that then they make you make the bread
and then turn the knob you know never
ask old people question then send you
forth to go do it you're right you don't
know how to do that all right let me
show you how did you did it not that I
don't want to do it so my grandmother
who was graduated from fourth grade took
a job scrubbing floors she didn't take
it it was given to her to supplement
many people sitting out there white
who've done the same thing not just a
black thing
leaving school at 4th grade some white
people made infirmary I don't know what
wife but he was made of a Spanish
Spanish made of funds for building
Filipino behind you those are people
said quit 4th grade they make it sound
like they quit they were told to quit
parents said we need money go to work
what do I do
shine this polish that blow that you
understand and so with grandmother
fourth grade I'm in college she said how
was it today
I just know and mothers just very
enlightening wonderful she's pounding on
the bread and beating rolling that you
know Anna got the glass cuz I want to
cut and make a biscuit you know just
give me one I throw it in the oven you
she was fighting with this dough flatten
it the beaten the roll never satisfied
she said but what was it about
and I hesitate I'm not gonna tell this
woman although she's very very bright
but she's not educated
I might going to explain their Hegel's
theory of dialect well you have the
proletariat and then you have the
deterrence and then you have any chariot
and the booty wire and their booty in
there she might even say how do you
spell it
she said well what else did you and I
said what we spent three hours
grandmother trying to find the answer is
the glass half full or half empty and my
grandmother said it depends on if you're
drinking up pouring
and Godspeed